1 hi I'm Jonathan reckford CEO of
Habitat for Humanity International and
we're a global NGO focused on housing
issues particularly creating and
bringing people together to build Decent
Homes and Communities one of the ideas
I've been really stuck by a west so far
is around the area of disaster response
and how we do a better job anticipating
it seem to be at this endless number of
natural disasters and man-made disasters
a particularly idea of coalition's
coming together private sector civil
society and governments to invest more
in mitigation in both the training but
also going in and making relatively
low-cost interventions in buildings and
homes that can greatly increase the
safety of the families when these
disasters come it is our goal and the
question i received from erica was
what's your vision for the rest of your
life and what will be your contribution
improving this day of the world soundly
my visions the rest of my life is to do
everything I can never world which
everyone has a decent place to live and
our hope is by bringing people together
to solve these huge problems we can make
sure that every child lives in somewhere
that has the chance to be healthy to get
an education it has the security of a
decent place to live thank you